>> YOU CAN AMISS KISS THE
AMERICA FIRST AGENDA GOODBYE.
WINDMILL, SOLAR PANELS AND CHIN
EATING OUR LUNCH.
BRIGHTNESS IN AMERICA IS BACK T
HER.
HE SAID TO MEET WITH TOP ALLIES
AT THE G7 IN ORDER TO COUNTER
CHALLENGES AND THREATS FROM
RUSSIA.
OUR TOP GENERAL ISSUED A WARNIN
TODAY ABOUT THESE INCREASED
CAPABILITIES.
CYBER TEXT WAS YOUR SERIOUS
THREAT.
>> AND THE FIRST ELECTED VICE
PRESIDENT UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA
THE MILITARY TOLD US WHAT THE
GREATEST PHYSICAL THREATS FACIN
AMERICA WAS.
RACE IS NOT A JOKE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE JOINT CHIEFS
TOLD US THE GREATEST FACING
AMERICA WAS?
LEVEL WARNING.
>> THE ONLY REASON HE SAID THIS
IS NOT A JOKE IS BECAUSE EVEN H
KNEW IT WAS A JOKE.
TO STATE THE OBVIOUS, GLOBAL
WARMING CAN'T SHUTDOWN YOUR GRI
OR.
BUT BIDEN SAID SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT WHEN HE WA
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST THREAT T
AMERICA RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF
BREAKING UP OUR SECURITY AND OU
ALLIANCE IS RUSSIA.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT GUY?
MAY BE GLOBAL WARMING RIDE HIS
BRAIN.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO ME?
>> I SAID THIS IS OFFENSIVE.
CAN GET YOU SAID IT WAS
OFFENSIVE WITH A GUTTURAL GROWL.
PEOPLE TAKING IT VERY SERIOUSLY
AND ASK HIM TO.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL SAY
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE AND THEIR
BIGGEST WORRY.
I KNOW THE MILITARY TAKES THE
ISSUE SERIOUSLY, HOWEVER WE ARE
ALSO DEALING WITH THE FACT THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT WERE IN A
COLD WAR, A SECOND COLD WAR WIT
CHINA, BUT I WAS REALLY.
THEY PUT THAT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
.
IF CHINA IS BUILDING A
COAL-FIRED POWER PLANTS PLANT
WEEK, THEN IF THE CLIMATE CHANG
ISSUE IT'S A GLOBAL ISSUE, CAN
SAY [BLEEP] IN THE WIN?
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE EU, THE
UNITED STATES AND CANADA TRYING
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS, BUT IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY DON'T.
I FELT LIKE THAT WAS A LITTLE
OFFENSIVE.
>> NOT AS OFFENSIVE AS USING
THAT LANGUAGE, BUT I'M SURE THE
CHILDREN ARE HOME ARE HAPPY TO
LEARN HOW TO SPELL NAUGHTY WORDS
.
HOW DO YOU HAVE TO HOW STUPID
YOU HAVE TO SAY AFTER A LAB
CREATED PANDEMIC TO SAY THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THAT.
YOU CALLING THE PRESIDENT STUPID
?
>> I WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
>> WHEN I THINK OF THREATS, I
THINK OF DEATH AND MONEY.
CLIMATE CHANGE HAS KILLED HOW
MANY PEOPLE?
ZERO.
THE CHINA VIRUS KILLED 600,000
IN THIS COUNTRY ALONE.
IF YOU INCLUDE THE FENNEL THAT
THEY BRING OVER, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF RETINAL DESK YEAR,
ISLAMIC TERROR, YOU COUNT THE
OVERSEAS WARS, YOU'RE TALKING
RUSSIAN HACKING, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS MAY BE OVE
100 MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, SO IT'
NOT A JOKE.
MAY BE THEY DID TELL THEM THAT.
IF THEY DID TELL THEM THAT THEY
SHOULD BE VIBRATE AND DON'T
THINK THEY EVEN SAID THAT I
THINK JOE DOESN'T EVEN REMEMBER
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
HAS NEVER SAID EVER, THAT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE NUMBER ON
THREAT.
HE JUST HAD TO COME OUT AND
CLARIFY THAT CHINA AND RUSSIA
ARE THE TOP THREATS.
MAY BE DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THEY THOUGHT THA
CLIMATE CHANGE WAS THE TOP
THREAT AND THAT WOULD EXPLAIN
HOW THEY MISSED ICES AND HOW TH
RUSSIANS AND THE CHINESE HACKED
US TO DEATH GREAT I THINK JOE
TRIES TO ELEVATE THE THREATS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE TO DISTRACT FROM
THE REAL PROBLEM THAT HE'S
BUNDLING LIKE THE CARTELS, LIKE
THE CYBER TERRORISTS AND LIKE
CHINA AND RUSSIA.
IT'S KIND OF A DEFLECTION AND
IT'S WEIRD, IT'S WEIRD BECAUSE
HE CAN'T KEEP TRACK OF ALL THE
THREATS THAT HE'S LISTED, LESS
TIME IT WAS WHITE SUPREMACY.
CAN GET THEY SHOULD COMBINE THE
TWO.
YOU SHOULD DO WHITE SUPREMACY
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE AND CALL IT
WHITE WEATHER.
>> VERY DANGER.
>> GLOBAL WHITENESS.
>> YOU WERE SCOWLING AT ME
BECAUSE YOU FIND THAT OFFENSIVE
YOU CAN BELIEVE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS AN ISSUE, BUT STILL
SEE THIS AS ABSURD BECAUSE
CLIMATE CHANGE, PEOPLE ARE
WORKING ON THAT YOU CAN WORK ON
IT OVER TIME, BUT IF IT'S NOT
INTENTIONALLY CLIMATE CHANGE
ISN'T TRAINED TWO KILL US, OVER
100 THAT IT COULD BE AN ISSUE.
IT WAS ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL TO
CALL IT RUSSIA SPECIFICALLY AND
HAVE THE DOG SPREAD LIKE THE 80
s CALLED AND THEY WOULD LIKE
THEIR FOREIGN-POLICY BACK ET
CETERA, BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE
TODAY IN OUR COUNTRY.
WE SPEND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS HERE THROUGH FEMA AN
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO REBUILD
CITIES LIKE HOUSTON, TO REBUILD
FLORIDA AFTER DON'T LOOK AT ME
LIKE THAT, JESSIE, IT'S TRUE.
>> I'M JUST TRYING NOT TO
INTERRUPT.
>> HOW DOES THAT APPLY TO
CLIMATE CHANGE BRETT.
>> IS A DESPERATE.
>> THEY SAY EXTREME WEATHER IS
NOT CORRELATED.
>> IT'S LIKE IT'S IN THERE.
EVEN THOUGH, THE BRUSHFIRES ARE
DECLINING OVER TIME COMPARED TW
SAY 100 YEARS AGO, I DON'T MEAN
TO POKE A HOLE IN YOUR THEORY,
BUT I DO.
>> I'M THRILLED FOR YOU TO DO I
AND I'M STICKING TWO MY GUNS ON
THIS ONE BECAUSE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT HAVE COME OUT OF
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND TRUMPET MINISTRATION WHERE
MIKE POMPEO HAD TO SAY YES,
REFUGEES ARE LEAVING THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES, ESPECIALLY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST BECAUSE OF THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE, SO T
KIND OF LAUGH IN THE FACE OF IT
AND CALL IT DUMB I THINK IS.
>> I AM NOT REFUTING ANY OF THAT
, BUT CLIMATE DOES PLAY A
PART IN HOW WE SEE MIGRATION.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S IN THE TO
SEVEN, KENNEDY.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
HERE PRO SCIENCE?
>> I LOVE SCIENCE.
>> GOING AFTER YOU, KENNEDY IS
GOING AFTER SCIENCE.
>> I'VE ALWAYS SAID IT, NO ONE
BELIEVES ME.
IT'S BECAUSE I LACK A DEGREE IN
ANYTHING SCIENTIFIC.
BUT HE'S RIGHT, IT'S ALL ABOUT
CHINA AND I THINK SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS THAT HE'S MADE IN TH
PAST ABOUT CHINA ARE GOING TO
COME BACK AND BITE HIM BECAUSE
HE'S LIKE CHINA IS NOT GOING TO
EAT OUR LUNCH, IT'S GLOBAL
WARMING AND THAT'S WHAT VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS SAID WHEN SHE
WENT TO GUATEMALA.
SHE SAID WE WANT TO MAKE
GUATEMALA GREAT AGAIN.
MEANWHILE, THEY ARE GROWING ALL
SORTS OF DRUGS AND HAVING THEM
IN THE JUNGLES OF GUATEMALA TER
OF THE DRUG WAR IS A MUCH BIGGE
DRIVER FOR PEOPLE LEAVING THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE THING CLIMATE
CHANGE EVER WILL BE.
IT'S NOT HIGH UP ON PEOPLE'S
LIST.
THEY DON'T WALK AROUND AND SAY
I'M SO WORRIED ABOUT THE CLIMATE
, I HAVE TO GET TO THE
U.S.
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHEN I SAW THAT STATEMENT THE
PRESIDENT MADE, THE ONLY THING
COULD PICTURE WERE PRESIDENTS O
THE PHONE JUST LAUGHING
HYSTERICALLY SAYING OH MY GOD,
AND THEN I WENT ONE STEP FURTHE
AND THOUGHT MAY MAYBE JOE BIDEN
IS LIKE KAISER SOSA, HE IS
TRYING TO BE THIS COMPLETE
DULLARD, BUT SECRETLY HE'S A
VILLAIN AND HE WANTS TO
COMPLETELY LOWER PEOPLE'S
EXPECTATIONS OF HIM AND THEN
HE'S GOING TO GO ALONG.
>> BIDEN DID INELASTIC.
>> IT'S SO EASY.
>> WAIT UNTIL YOUR BOOK COMES
OUT.
>> IT IS THE EQUIVALENT OF
POSTING THIRSTY PICTURES ON
INSTAGRAM, THE POLITICAL
EQUIVALENT.
THE IN A WAY TO SPOIL THE
FIDELITY OF ALL THE USUAL
SUSPECTS